lohan allait régulièrement à l'hôpital
elle est suivie à des amis qui sont là
pour elle je pense qu'elle a sorti de sa
vie les fréquentations qui était
mauvaise pour elle donc aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qu'on peut lui souhaiter à
parfaire ce qu'elle a envie de faire et
des projets qu'ils épanouie ce sens est
vrai que la démo projets communs en
courant elle soir à 10 kg
elle prépare un cabaret c'est bien ou
très bien d'accord mais c'est votre
village ou matin de ce que vous direz
c'est vrai que c'est pas on a envie
quelle qu'elle soit j'aimerais vraiment
que malakoff c'est pas bien ce que vous
faites c'est promis d'instaurer vous
faites séditieux je tenais à vous dire
je vous prie je vous mets un blâme et je
vous met un carton jaune pour cette
remarque c'est un signe aux voilà c'est
complètement nul
les amis en france et je vaux je me
vengerai nicolas pernikoff je vous jure
que je me vengerai on va faire un point
sur tout élément derrière en plus tu te
mangerais on va faire le point sur leurs
michel bancaire c'est à les renvoyer au
lieu dit bois
[Musique]
des annonces ont été faites par jean
michel blanquer quels sont les annonces
valérie bénaïm direct 20h42 écoutez sert
visiblement il a écouté ce qui s'est
passé sur le plateau de touche pas à mon
poste avec vous et des étudiants puisque
finalement la meilleure note sera
retenue entre celles de l'épreuve de
philosophie et le contrôle continu c'est
ce qui vient d'annoncer donc du coup il
y aura c'est enfin un entre-deux en fait
c'est à dire qu'il maintient quand même
son histoire de l'examen final et en
même temps elle contrôle continu pour
les horribles au cra aussi quand on a
parlé apparemment il n'aurait plus de 12
épreuves à passer mais moins on le saura
dans un instant à dire exactement
combien
mais apparemment ce serait la papauté la
moitié donc voilà donc ça a bougé ça va
encore bouger et pour les bts pour les
bts il va repréciser les choses decroix
puisqu'il ya déjà des choses qui ont été
faites il valait repréciser pour
vraiment con et tout ça en tête et que
les études en bts et tous en tête mais
ça bouge ça bouge on est bien content
bon vous était très inquiet pour les
contrats ce kurde et raturer et
quimperlé golf bon sérieuses émergent
nous avons une édition est donc non mais
j'ai manqué la bonne nouvelle c'est que
les choses auront avancés avec des pmp
on en a pas arrêtez arrêtez tout cela on
en a parlé lundi ou mardi dans
l'émission car il est sûr que ça avance
et grâce à tpm php journal aux ratés du
gazole ont changé il est toujours là par
les ja pour les biens et une réaction
dans les bacs ce sera la mère d'antoine
entre le le contrôle continu arrêté
arrêté et a été arrêté derrière aussi
donc le contre côté pour le bac on fera
la meilleure note super bravo mais dont
les jolies et c'est très bien merci
saint jean lachalm entière les regarde
et bnp qui a interdit dans tpm pc
allez-y tout prix eh ben on passait à
l'expression mais non on peut pas
masquer sociaux non non il faut
continuer l'émission accord non mais ce
qui est bien c'est que ça a fait bouger
les choses et conscience que c'est un
vrai poids dans la vie politique voilà
exactement non mais c'est vrai que bon
alors c'est pour les hors contrat non
jeu
l'un d'eux pour leur contrat par contre
c'est pas tout à fait car il a dit qu'il
allait prendre
il allait alléger de programmes passes
québécois 13 matchs et a passé à
privilégier le contrôle continu ce qui
est bien pour les étudiants mais pas
pour nous ce n'est pas pour les rendre
leur contrat ils vont passer tout
quelques matières mais moi exactement
voilà ça ça qui est important merci
beaucoup aller alors là pour le coup
c'est pas du tout drôle ce qu'on va ce
qu'on va parler maintenant c'était le
moment fort de les chaudières c'est
évidemment le débat entre et débats très
tendu entre entre tawaf et à bruno attal
regarder tourner aujourd'hui vous quand
vous avez entendu le témoignage de tommy
y est qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
avez à répondre de cette histoire et
tout ce qui s'est passé lors de son
interpellation un bain il a très bien
choisi son pseudo tournuit c'est pas le
verlan de mythos